[Applause]
maybe we can meet you can I just say
from me and all of Texas you are doing
us my band is from the area so yes Katie
Beaumont all that suit repping us right
girl you thank you as well with all your
billion views this is I know we started
on YouTube and even more so how do you
get billions of views I'm just asking
for a friend
other than keeping it on loop in the
background of my house at all times
you know I started originally on vine so
it was six second long videos that I was
making rest in peace I pull one out
every time in so I went on over into
YouTube because I can talk a lot longer
than that my first youtube video was 12
minutes long and now I'm making 22
minute half-hour TV show do I got a 22
minute half-hour comedy but the elderly
so I learned all about YouTube through
my boy you don't go down the rabbit hole
well you see watch puppy videos or cat
videos eating what I want I open I go to
my son's room and that's all they watch
they're not watching television shows
unless it's on YouTube so you're exactly
where 17 oh that's my demographic sure
but you have college to make youtube
videos so exactly how excited were your
parents about this they were they were
the ones that actually encouraged me to
like personally my dreams to move out to
LA so y know right I had the blessing of
a brown parent you know that don't have
another day
I did I did so my dad and my mom
actually met in theater class in college
and my dad was told he would only be
like stereotype cast as a brown man and
so now here I am being a brown girl
doing all the both of them are like
that's not I'd like to say my sister
says I stole her personality identical
so how do you feel anything Lisa um so
it was like your favorite person you've
ever had on your YouTube channel lucky
enough I had Barack Obama president what
was that like were you nervous
oh so nervous the man walked into room
he smelled like all types of pumpkin
spice fall candles like these every is a
dryer sheet known to man that's what he
smells like oh my god did you play
himself I would love to see him playing
[Laughter]
when we all vote campaign what is that
so that I am a part of the basically me
meeting uh mr. president of Barack Obama
it was kind of like my audition to work
with Miss Michelle Obama our first vote
campaign I'm part of her voting squad to
kind of get my audience and give my
youngsters out there to go out there and
empower them to use their tell me about
lies on demand 74 million people oh my
god 74 74 million people saw season
two's first episode I can't even get the
number out cuz it's so big
insane I know it's absolutely embrace to
them just a few of the video make sure
to check out the season of William
Grayson
yeah now that is amazing like do you
just get everywhere you go then it must
be everywhere just like oh my gosh it's
pretty well people say hey but I love
meeting them and I'm like thank you so
much for watching I don't know it's mild
it's hard to like fathom that many
people there well you're a blessing your
authentic your cool that's why it's
reading very well so I'm very happy
[Applause]
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going